mais d'abord cette crise migratoire aux
portes de l'europe les ministres des
affaires étrangères étaient réunis à
bruxelles pour décider qui et comment
sanctionner gaspard flamand ce soir plus
de 2000 migrants dormiront à la
frontière entre le bélarus et la pologne
dont des femmes enceintes et des enfants
dans des conditions très précaires avec
des températures en dessous de zéro
degré malgré les difficultés certains
essaient de franchir la frontière
polonaise souvent arrêtés ramener en
biélorussie ce matin alexandre
loukachenko affirme vouloir apaiser la
situation
nous sommes prêts comme de coutume à
mettre tout le monde dans des avions
notamment ceux de bellavia qui les
ramèneront chez eux mais ces gens je
dois dire sont très têtu personne ne
veut rentrer
à bruxelles les 27 ministres des
affaires étrangères réunis la cus
pourtant d'organiser cet afflux de
migrants par vengeance pour répondre aux
sanctions qui lui avait été infligée
suite à sa répression violente de
l'opposition l'année dernière du côté de
la lituanie pays voisins du bélarus on
peine à croire les promesses d'alexandre
loukachenko
je n'ai aucune raison de croire que ce
qu'il dit est vrai car la plupart des
choses qui sont sortis de minsk l'année
dernière après le vol des élections
étaient principalement de la propagande
store de l'iphone os monthly propagande
lieu prévoit aussi des sanctions
punitives dont les grandes lignes ont
été données par le chef de la diplomatie
européenne
nous allons donner le feu vert à un
élargissement du cadre juridique de nos
sanctions contre la biélorussie par
exemple les compagnies aériennes ou les
agences de voyages impliqué en
interdisant leur dirigeant de voyager et
engelland leurs actifs en europe depuis
le début de cette crise migratoire onze
personnes ont perdu la vie
quand sortir de ce piège biélorusse ce
quelle réponse l'europe peut-elle donner
on en débat tout de suite avec mes
invités patricia allemonière avant soit
grand sortir spécialiste de politique
internationale
christian lequesne bonsoir professeur à
sciences po vous publiez la puissance
par l'image les états et leur diplomatie
publique c'était aux presses de sciences
po gérard françois dumont bonsoir vous
êtes géographes économistes démographes
directeur de la revue population et
avenir et vous publiez géopolitique de
l'europe c'est aux presses
universitaires de france avec nous en
visioconférence j'accueille également
guillaume klossa qu'est le fondateur du
think tank europanova conseiller spécial
de jean pierre jouyet pendant la
présidence française de l'union
européenne ce et est en 2008 voilà une
expérience sur laquelle on va aussi
pouvoir s'appuyer et puis matthieu
croissandeau je pense qu'en politique
comme chaque lundi et mercredi bonsoir
bienvenue mathieu alors les deux
dernières informations elles sont
tombées quasiment juste avant le
générique de cette émission annonce de
l'union européenne par la voix de josep
borrell son haut représentant
pour les affaires étrangères et la
politique de sécurité de l'union
européenne va adopter de nouvelles
sanctions dans les prochains jours
certes le train de sanctions a été
validé et on aura les détails dans les
prochains jours et puis autre
information venue de la pologne cette
fois la pologne annonce la construction
d'un mur à la frontière construction qui
débutera début décembre 180 km prévus la
moitié de la frontière entre la pologne
et la biélorussie pour un montant total
de 353 millions d'euros voilà les deux
toute dernière annonce peut-être pour
démarrer patricia allemonière le les
enjeux pour l'union européenne peut-être
qu'il ya un premier enjeu quels enjeux
de la rapidité montrer qu'on réagit tout
simplement mais les lignes européennes
est prise entre deux j'avais été entre
deux choses d'un côté il y à ces images
d'une extrême violence de ces gens qui
sont coincés deux entre finalement 2-2
frange de soldats dans le froid dans le
gel avec ses morts évidemment le
président biélorusse met en avant ses
femmes et ses enfants pour parce qu'il
sait très bien que chez nous ça marche
donc voilà il et puis l'union européenne
et qu'on essaie avec aussi cette réalité
de si on accepte ces vingt mille est-ce
que c'est pas la porte ouverte à autre
chose et je crois qu'en fait
l'éternel débat de l'aaapnb l'éternel
débat qu'on a eu en une heure dans
l'union européenne am de multiples
reprises on l'a eue avec la turquie on
l'a eue avec la libye on l'a eue avec le
maroc on a eu de multiples fois mais là
en plus derrière je crois que il y a
autre chose c'est que si on accepte de
céder à la pression c'est effectivement
une vulnérabilité de leurs rangs par
rapport à tous ces pays parce qu'il faut
bien dire qu'aujourd'hui l'europe c'est
une zone de richesse une zone où il ya
de la sécurité sociale des services de
santé l'éducation plutôt abordable
pouvoir gratuite et pour tous les pays
qui sont en train de se disloquer parce
qu'il faut bien dire tout le monde des
retours c'est c'est un monde de guerre
c'est un monde qui s'écroule l'afrique
le moyen-orient le proche-orient de rien
ne vend donc pour tous ces gens qui sont
soit des réfugiés économiques si on me
dira pressé par le saleh sahel le
réchauffement climatiques la
désertification soit par les guerres
l'europe et est un aspirateur parce que
vous le feriez pas mal vous auriez une
petite famille vous vivriez au liban
avec rien pour manger qu'est ce que vous
voyez vous dirai peut-être que je vais y
aller peut-être que je vais tenter donc
c'est humain mais en même temps on peut
pas accueillir comme certains l'ont dit
avant moi toute la misère du monde parce
que c'est nos services sociaux qui
craque et c'est nos populations
immigrées qu'on a du mal à absorber qui
craquent aussi donc on et priant dans en
2008 on en reviendra sûrement oui on
reviendra comme ça où on avait les mêmes
problèmes déjà avec christian le guen
c'est ce sentiment d'être pris au piège
effectivement ceux qui sont d'abord que
au piège ce sont les les familles d des
femmes des enfants des hommes on le
disait mais pour l'europe c'est quand
même effectivement un piège arias une
première alors la première réponse
parler de rapidité bon je sais pas si on
est vraiment dans la réaction que l'on
annonce de nouvelles sanctions
oui alors choisir de ne pas attendre
comme sanction d'ailleurs à écouter il
ya déjà des sanctions légales à de la
bélarussie donc ça veut dire qu'on va
aller qu'on va les augmenter mais en
même temps on les annonce ce qui veut
dire qu'on se laisse une petite marge de
négociation je ne serais pas étonné que
si on a simplement dit qu'on les
annonçait c'est parce que monsieur
loukachenko a commencé un petit peu a
discuté non voilà d'ailleurs ça ne vous
a pas échappé il a fait une déclaration
dans la journée disons qu'il allait
commencer à renvoyer les réfugiés que
c'était bien sûr qu'ils ne voulaient pas
partir lui faisait tout pour qu'il en
soit ainsi mais ça ça veut dire qu'il a
il faut bien comprendre que ce petit
pays est quand même très enclavée dans
l'union européenne et d'un point de vue
économique ou d'un point de vue de la
liberté de circulation des cadres du
régime disons ça les embête quand même
ce régime de sanctions donc je ne serais
pas étonné qui est une quête une
négociation
ça ne veut pas dire que tous les que
tous les réfugiés vont forcément rentrée
est là comme vous le disiez très bien
l'union européenne a des valeurs nous
sommes quand même une
organisation qui repose sur les
principes de l'état de droit nous nous
devons de faire en sorte que ces
réfugiés famille enfants etc soient
convenablement traité au moins cons et
qu'on écoute leur leur témoignage pour
savoir si à certains d'entre eux on
donnera le statut de de réfugiés gérard
françois dumont c'est quoi c'est un bras
de fer c'est un rapport de force qu'il
faut instaurer entre
l'union européenne alors la biélorussie
puis évidemment à parler derrière lui
aussi la russie vladimir poutine ben
bien entendu nous sommes un des rapports
de force géopolitique asie aux
politiques ce ne sont que des rapports
de science est donc là la grosse erreur
d'ailleurs c'est que j'entends ces jours
ci des mots employés comme chantage
bluff c'est des mots qui ne n'ont aucune
signification réelle donc en fait on a
des situations d'abord où l'union
européenne montre sa fragilité et son
incapacité à décider fragilité parce que
vous rappeler que la nouvelle présidente
de la commission européenne avait
déclaré que cette fois ci il y aura une
commission géopolitique bon
malheureusement on voit que l'europe
n'arrive pas à définir une stratégie
géopolitique et pourtant elle avait fait
une avancée notoire en mars 2020 quand
vous vous rappelez erdogan à nouveau
avait essayé d'utiliser larmes des
immigrants à des fins géopolitiques et
là la présidente de la commission le
président du parlement européen et le
président du conseil européen s'était
rendu à la frontière entre la turquie et
la grèce pour bien dire à erdogan ont
maintenant ça suffit vous n'avez pas
recommencer comme avant je vous rappelle
qu'avant les experts eux mêmes et même
les dirigeants officielle disait que
erdogan avait transformé la turquie en
autoroute à migrants et c'était bien ce
qui s'était passé seulement
malheureusement comme vous le savez en
2015 et 2016 surtout l'union européenne
avait cédé jeudi mien elle avait cédé
pourquoi parce qu'il ya eu ce fameux
accord à la turquie avec des promesses
de plusieurs milliers d'euros à la
turquie en contrepartie qu'ils arrêtent
de faire la turquie une autoroute à
migrants mais quand cette décision a été
prise d'autres méthodes aurait été
possible puisque l'autriche de son côté
avec quelques pays avait fermé la route
des balkans donc avait déjà réussi à
avancer donc le problème c'est vraiment
on a d'une part ces stratégies
géopolitiques d'autre part il faut
toujours se rappeler la stratégie
géopolitique de la russie elle est telle
depuis 1990 la russie
restant sur l'héritage de l'urss avait
négocié avec les états unis pourrait
coûter bon on ne parle plus d héritage
de l'urss mais au moins n'avancez pas le
temps vers nous c'était la discussion
des années 90 entre les états unis et la
russie or les états unis n'ont pas tenu
leurs promesses et donc à chaque fois
qu'il y a eu une avancée de l'otan est
ce que c'est bien le seul langage que
vladimir poutine peut entendre
finalement oui mais les suns action que
veux tu que vladimir poutine ce qu'il
veut c'est un sas géopolitique un sa
géopolitique de la russie par rapport à
l'extérieur et donc on voit bien que
quand on a voulu faire commencer des
éléments faisant très la jour la géorgie
dans le temps guerre en géorgie quand on
a dit l'ukraine va entrer dans le temps
conflit en ukraine pour l'art ici pour
la syrie c'est exactement la même chose
parce qu'on règle était la syrie fait
partie du ca géopolitique de la russie
puisque la russie a besoin de la syrie
pour ses bases militaires et pour avoir
l'ouverture sur les mers chaudes
guillaume klossa vous attendez à quoi
vous comme comme sanctions elles seront
peut-être par les tient de de sanctions
aux portefeuilles notamment pour les
compagnies aériennes qu'est ce qu'on
peut attendre de la part de ces deux là
par deux mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que les sanctions qui ont été
faites sur les dirigeants et le russe ça
marche pas forcément en revanche ses
fonctions qui marche c'est les sanctions
qui s'adresse aux compagnies aériennes
aux agences de voyages qui sont dans les
pays qui sont fournisseurs de mes grands
l'irak
bon tout cas de transit la jordanie est
le seul fait d'annoncer ses fonctions
ces sanctions a fait que le liban l'irak
la jordanie a annoncé qu'elle arrêtait
les les vols vers la terre la bélarusse
donc l'union européenne quand elle
traite déjà les dires des puissances ou
des pays de second rang à une vraie à
une vraie influence et pour l'irak pour
le liban pour la jordanie européen c'est
une puissance le sujet en fait c'est le
jeu de moscou et moscou ce qu'il veut
c'est profiter de toutes les failles de
l'union européenne parce que l'union
européenne est le seul modèle entre
guillemets civilisationnel alternatif
pour les russes et bon qui menace qui
menacent poutine et poutine c'est que
avec la question migratoire
il touche toutes les opinions publiques
européennes jusqu'à zemmour en france et
y génèrent des réactions contre les
valeurs européennes notamment l'idée
d'un mur aux frontières de la pologne
alors 120 kw en dix jours c'est bien
d'un point de vue tactique et j'ai donc
les premières menaces de sanctions par
rapport aux pays émetteurs ou de transit
sont très efficaces il faut le dire je
reprends la main une seconde parce que
vous quittiez la yacht sur le liban on
vous dit que le liban a pas arrêté pour
l'instant pour l'instant il ya un pays
qui a qui arrêtent et qu'il a annoncé
effectivement c'est la turquie un autre
pays c'est un des pays c'est des émirats
je crois que les deux camps au liban le
liban est dans une telle situation je
déstructuré ya une compagnie je crois
qu'a annoncé effectivement qui partait
de beyrouth a annoncé qu'elle mais c'est
pas le c'est pas le liban en tant que
tel modèle et je crois que je crois que
les sanctions - je suis très réservé sur
les sanctions on met des sanctions quand
on ne veut pas faire la guerre on met
des sanctions quand on quand on veut
faire pression sur le porte-monnaie ce
qu'on est très bien dit parfois ça
marche mais globalement qui l'une est
très bonne étude qui a été faite par un
5 5 ha à genève qui montrait que les
sanctions économiques qui avait étudié
toutes les sanctions économiques des
nations unies ces derniers années m'ont
montré quel marché qu'à 22 20 20 25% des
idées donc les sanctions c'est pour
quand même dire aux gens attention
bouger mais voilà c'est tout et donc les
compagnies aériennes pour revenir et
finir le boulot parce que je vois que
vous dites que yoann est parti ou
aérienne ce sont soit des compagnies
d'état comme dans leur élan la turquie
c'est un état qui décide et hop vous
m'avez vous oublie ses soins dans un
état où il n'y a pas d'état comme au
liban ça peut être que des petites
compagnies individuelle et privés et là
c'est beaucoup plus dur pas parce que ma
chère à cette dérive parce que christian
lequesne ça rapporte aussi c'est trivial
mais c'est cette histoire ça rapporte à
certaines compagnies aériennes bien sûr
c'est environ 1000 1500 euros rien que
le trajet si vous voulez ensuite
s'ajoutent les visas les services pour
accéder à l'ambassade de biélorussie et
c'est donc ça fait marcher l'économie
libanaise dans une période de crise
assez terrible et je crois qu'on ne doit
pas s'attendre à une très forte
régulation de la part de l'état libanais
là ce sont vraiment des intérêts
économiques de court terme qui qui
explique pourquoi les compagnies se sont
se sont rués sur ses voyages vers minsk
alors vous parliez la nôtre évidemment
mais à les autres de du rôle de vladimir
poutine on va écouter le président russe
c'était le 13 novembre il rejette
évidemment toute responsabilité je veux
que tout le monde le sache nous n'avons
absolument rien à voir là dedans tout le
monde essaye de nous rendre responsables
des choses pour quelques raisons que ce
soir pour aucune raison nos compagnies
aériennes ne transporte pas ce personnes
aucune de nos entreprises ne le fait
mathieu vladimir poutine qui qui
s'invite aussi dans la campagne
française c'est ça qui est intéressant
de venir patiner l'isère toujours une
forme de fascination répulsion dans la
classe politique française c'est un peu
l'invité surprise de cette campagne dont
peu comme la dernière fois mais un petit
peu plus et à ses admirateurs évidemment
comme eric zemmour qui rêvait autrefois
d'un boot inn français et qui saluait le
maître du kremlin pour avoir restauré
l'âme russe il dit de lui que c'est la
grèce et celle agressé que c'est pas
l'agresseur dans le dossier ukrainien
pour lui c'est un patriote russe raid
comme il dit c'est pas un prêt unis
suédois est donc en gros il a une
fascination pour la dîmière poutine
homme fort et surtout une façon
désarrimée la france et l'union la
france en tout cas de l'otan et de la
tutelle de la tutelle américaine cette
fascination la retrouve aussi toujours
l'extrême droite chez marine le pen a
lancé sur un peu sur un autre registre
puisque même la russie enfin des banques
russes qu'on entend financer son parti
ni c'est en russie que la demi-heure
routine avait reçu ou sonné par la
campagne présidentielle en 2017 c'est la
russie qui était parti une halle et
macronix les fameuses fuites la veille
avec du second tour bref on voit que
l'un comme l'autre mais aussi nicolas
dupont aignan qui avait quand même cette
formule mémorable le seul chef d'état au
monde c'est vladimir poutine avec lui
dit
tous rejettent la ligne dure assorties
de sanctions là il appelle à renouer
évidemment
allo dialogue avec la russie un
rapprochement et le crémant c'était une
vision qui est également partagée en
2017 par un dénommé françois fillon et
est ce que c'est une position qui
continue de rencontrer du succès à
droite alors avec quelques bémols parce
qu'il y ait un débat chez les
républicains hier qu'on a pu voir
vladimir poutine il s'appelle pas tous
comme fillon qui avait des liens assez
serré avec le kremlin et enfin en tout
cas avec la russie à arnaud et d une
forme d'alliance on va dire mais ils en
font un bond repoussoir pour afficher
leur prétendue fermeté écouter ce que
disent et valérie pécresse par exemple
hier sur bfm tv
s'agissant de la russie il faut
évidemment un dialogue et ne pas
dialoguer avec là aussi c'est une faute
mais il faut un dialogue pardon de
l'expression extrêmement ferme
extrêmement ferme sans naïveté et sans
compromission parce que les russes ne
respecte que les rapports de force et il
faut le savoir et quand on le sait eh
bien ça conduit à être évidemment
exigeant dans le dialogue avec la russie
voilà un dialogue avec la russie tout en
se montrant très ferme oui pour lui dire
quoi ça faudra attendre parce que pour
l'instant la balle arrive à la gauche et
à gauche alors évidemment nié toute une
partie de la gauche qui dénonce la
demi-heure tout in haut qui dénonce la
mascarade démocratique qui fait qu'il se
maintient au pouvoir qui n'est en ce
qu'il le rôle qu'y joue avec ses
opposants qui dénoncent écoute force et
puis on en est quand même un peu fasciné
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui multiplie
les clins d'oeil à l'égard de la russie
mélenchon qui avait salué l'intervention
russe en disant que c'était la seule qui
pouvait éradiquer des chemins mélenchon
qui plaide et plus récemment pour
commander des doses de vaccin skotnik on
s'en souvient et qui souhaite lui aussi
sortir de l'otan pour finir avec cette
alliance north american comme il dit et
qu'il faut plutôt renouer le dialogue
avec avec la russie au fond y en a qu'un
qui était sur une ligne vraiment
d'opposition à au kremlin en tout cas
pas d'opposition mais de fermeté c'est
emmanuel macron pour le coup il était le
seul la dernière fois françois fillon
jean luc mélenchon marine le pen était
plutôt pro-russe on verra ce que ça
donne en 2022 mais si on à eric zemmour
marine le pen peut-être jean luc
mélenchon encore on sera peut-être dans
une situation incertaine dans la même
situation là gérard françois dumont
c'est qu'elle est ce qu'on peut parler
d'une stratégie de la russie et donc de
son omni président
déstabilisation de démocratie européenne
tous on a suffisamment d'éléments depuis
des années pour la stratégie ça comment
ça consiste à vouloir que les pays
européens
soient utiles aux intérêts de la russie
et pour cela la meilleure méthode pour
lui c'est diviser pour régner des
affaires donc vous voyez bien north
stream par exemple qui est en fait une
façon d'obliger l'allemagne est très
proche de la russie mais vous vous avez
bien vu bien entendu que nord stream
contournant la pologne 1 celui qui n'est
pas hasard bien sûr nous la france on
est plutôt avantagé parce qu'on est
assez peu dépendante de la russie pour
nos fournitures notamment d'énergie
notamment grâce à l'importante de leur
énergie nucléaire on voit très bien
aussi le rôle de la russie dans les
balkans on voit le rôle d'aro de la
russie avec la hongrie donc clairement
si vous voulez au lieu de considérer
l'union européenne comme une entité
homogène et avec laquelle il faut
discuter et bien en fait la russie
préfère le prendre séparément chacun des
pays d'europe et et voir comment
profiter leur existence mais ça c'est
intéressant parce que loukachenko aux
menaces de couper l'approvisionnement en
gaz en fait ça n'arrange pas vladimir
poutine poutine il a envie de montrer un
partenaire fiable un fournisseur fiable
et précis en réalité monsieur poutine
n'a aucun intérêt particulier aucun
sentiment particulier pour le dictateur
de biélorussie son souci c'est
qu'effectivement la biélorussie restent
autant que possible un partenaire de la
russie et que la bio lloris il ne tombe
pas agir est dans le camp de l'union
européenne est en fait dans le camp de
l'otan puisque vos je vous rappelle que
à chaque fois qu'il ya eu d
élargissement de l'union européenne les
pays ont adhéré d'abord à l'otan et
ensuite seulement après à l'union
européenne donc c'est ça son objectif
est donc dans cette situation là eh bien
il veut conserver la biélorussie plus
près de lui que de bruxelles
sur la stratégie sur cette question de
la stratégie et du et du gaz il faut se
souvenir que durant toute la guerre
froide
mais approvisionnement en gaz se sont
poursuivies donc ça c'est un point
important c'est sa ressource vitale
exporter le gaz donc me vladimir poutine
est un homme qui sait très bien qu'il a
besoin d'argent donc il va pas nous il
va pas nous couper du gaz il faut il
faut le croire et d'ailleurs et donc ça
veut dire quoi c'est à dire que
loukachenko on n'a pas vraiment le
pouvoir
on n'a pas le voir il dépend entièrement
de vladimir poutine pour faire tourner
ses usines par exemple il ya beaucoup de
raffineries en biélorussie pour les
faire tourner il faut que moscou
approvisionne en pétrole je vous donne
que cet exemple mais en plus dans cette
histoire de gaz ça serait de très
mauvais augure pour les négociations sur
le nord stream 2 si vladimir poutine
coupe est allé dans le sens de du
président biélorusse parce que vous
savez très bien que ce fameux gazoduc
effectivement il est fini il est il
commença est approvisionné mais ce n'est
pas totalement finie c'est pas signé
complètement cette histoire c'est pas
totalement ficelé alors il va pas se
couper quand même la pso le piège la
demo routine puisque son histoire de
nord stream ii n'est pas sécurisé il
attend un peu comme de ceux de sécuriser
et vous savez que la dépendance de
l'europe est grave parce qu'on est à
plus de 45% de dépendance de gaz
vis-à-vis des russes donc voilà
on peut aller plus loin avec vous
guillaume klossa là on était vraiment
sur les revient sur la question de la
réponse européenne on était sûr la
réponse on va dire à court terme
sanctions quel type de sanctions
pourquoi on les retards de quelle
stratégie peut y avoir derrière mais
mais sur la politique migratoire parce
que finalement cette crise elle
questionne aussi la politique migratoire
européenne
quelles réponses peut-on attendre
d'après vous le les européens et la
commission a proposé un pacte pacte que
migratoires qui
depuis quelques mois déjà et qui me
bloquer un accord des européens et on
voit que il ya une grande division sur
les approches des différences est un
nombre en matière en matière migratoire
je pense que le dossier pourrait avancer
qu'une fois les élections
françaises passées et qu'un gouvernement
stable soit en allemagne parce que la
vérité c'est qu'il ya une sorte de vide
politique sur le sujet migratoires
aujourd'hui et qu'on a besoin d'eux de
plusieurs états européens qu'ils soient
en puissance en situation de décider et
le contexte électoral en france
absence de gouvernement en allemagne et
non volonté de jouer le jeu en pologne
et est problématique et fait que les
européens n'arrivent pas à définir une
stratégie dilatoire migratoire commune
donc je ne pense que ça sera possible
que que qu'après les élections
françaises et et l'arrivée d'un
gouvernement en allemagne et j'irai même
plus
semblant à nouveau gouvernement pour
l'année parce que le sujet mega thouars
n'est pas une compétence de l'union à
proprement parler millions à à des bouts
de compétences en matière de migration
qui sont qui sont très limités alors
qu'il ya à l'unité politique parole dans
un instant guillaume klossa je vous
redonne la parole dans un instant je
voudrais que quentin calmer nos nous
rejoignent parce que vous allez donner
un certain nombre de détails sur ce
pacte migratoires mais d'abord le
travail que les sénateurs ont rendu
aussi c'est fin septembre c'est ça
exactement ils ont travaillé sur ce que
vient d'évoquer à votre invité à
l'instant c'est à dire ce nouveau pacte
sur la migration et d'asile qui a été
présenté par la commission européenne ce
et le 23 septembre 2020 ce plan est
toujours en cours d'adoption par les
états membres et c'est sur ces
négociations qu'on travaillait les
sénateurs on va y revenir l'idée de ce
plan on s'en rappelle 1,7 et de répondre
à la crise migratoire de 2015-2016 que
vous avez aussi évoqué sur ce plateau
selon ursula von der leyen il s'agissait
avec ce paquet de mesures d'un nouveau
départ je cite avec trois points qu'on a
retenue dans cette réforme durcir les
renvoient des migrants irréguliers
mettre en place des contrôles accrus aux
frontières extérieures créer des
procédures accélérées surtout pour les
ressortissants de pays où les demandes
d'asile sont largement refusée et enfin
mettre en place un nouveau mécanisme de
solidarité entre les états membres et
c'est là que vous allez le comprendre ça
coince cet accord est donc toujours en
cours de négociation cela patine entre
les états membres et c'est donc là
dessus qu'on travaillait les sénateurs
dans le titre du rapport le sénat parle
d'une union européenne entre divisions
persistantes et nécessaire solidarité on
le sait la compétence en matière
d'immigration c'est une compétence
partagée entre les états membres et
l'union européenne d'où la difficulté à
on comprend à trouver un accord chaque
pays ayant sa propre conception son
propre agenda en la matière il ya donc
trois visions dans ce dossier d'un côté
les pays d'europe centrale opposé à ce
pacte présenté en septembre 2020 avec à
leur tête ce fameux groupe devise grade
vous savez la hongrie la pologne la
slovaquie la république tchèque il ya
les états membres qui eux sont et bien
les premières portes d'entrée à la miga
la migration en europe la grèce l'italie
l'espagne qui eux prônent davantage de
solidarité sont favorables aux pactes et
puis il ya au milieu les états membres
comme la france ou l'allemagne qui tente
de trouver un compromis cette opposition
d'ailleurs entre les pays membres elle
est peut-être en train de changer avec
ce qui se passe en biélorussie mais les
négociations autour de ce pacte ce sera
une des missions de la france
lorsqu'elle présidera la présidence
tournante de l'union européenne à partir
de janvier prochain et donc ils vont
peut-être essayer de trouver le plus
petit dénominateur commun entre toutes
ces mesures du pacte avec peut-être des
mesures assez technique merci beaucoup
quentin pour ces pour ses explications
guillaume klossa je rappelle que vous
étiez aux côtés de de jean pierre jouyet
lors de la précédente présidence
tournante présidence française de
l'union s'est éteint en 2008 qu'est ce
que qu'est-ce que hergé ouvrir mon
sentiment sur plein de dossiers depuis
depuis un mois j'entends mes
interlocuteurs me dit ah heureusement la
france d'avoir la présidence française
l'union comme si c'était une espèce de
grâce à l'échangé
peut-être qu'il faut calmer un peu tout
le monde
oui parce que la présidence de 2008
c'est pas du tout la présidence de
2002 2022 dans la mesure où la
présidence que nous avions était une
présidence du conseil européen
que qu'assumer nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui avec les institutions
lisbonne depuis donc
2000-2009 qu'il ya un président stable
du conseil européen qui s'appelle
charles michel et donc c'est présicent
président cela très politique la france
ne l'assument pas et puis il ya une
présidence du conseil de l'union
européen c'est à dire tu es des sections
ministérielles spécialisées
qui comprend notamment la section
affaires étrangères mais l'appareil
aujourd'hui il ya un pilote qui est
joseph bourrel qui préside les conseils
des ministres affaires étrangères et de
la défense et c'est plus le ministre
français qui préside donc sur ces sujets
la marge de manoeuvre françaises et la
capacité d'impulsion elle est beaucoup
plus limité que ya 14 ans et puis un
deuxième sujet c'est que quand vous
arrivez vous êtes tout juste élu vous
avez une capacité d'influencé qui est
considérable c'est très très difficile à
la fin d'un mandat et je crois qu'ils
emmanuel macron est tout à fait
conscient qu'il a une fenêtre de tir
pour influencer les décisions
européennes qui est entre le 1er janvier
et début de la présidence et mi mars
début de la campagne de la campagne
électorale vous voyez c'est c'est une
présidence doublement limité sur
lesquels il ne faut pas avoir trop
d'attentes et notamment en matière
migratoire je ne sens pas que la la
présidence française pense sérieusement
qu'elle puisse avoir un accord important
sur le pacte sur l'immigration et
l'asile et l'asile européen en revanche
ce qui se passe quand il ya des crises
graves il ya toujours une capacité
d'influencé vous avez vu pendant la
présidence allemande de l'union
européenne
il ya eu cet accord sur sur le plan de
relance européen qui qui a été facilité
par la présidence allemande donc s'il ya
de grosses crises emmanuel macron aura
son mot à dire et aura une capacité de
médiation forte alors vous devrez vous
entendre sur sa vague de migratoire
peut-être christian lequesne pour pour
commencer je viens vers vous juste après
jean françois dumont est ce que quand
j'entendais quant à tout à l'heure
j'étais en train de me dire bon bah ça
n'arrivera jamais quoi c'est une et
intérêts non annoncé je pense que vous
avez raison il ya de fortes chances pour
que ça ne débouche sur rien d'autre que
sur des déclarations d'une église at war
et des des intentions on veut dire si un
sujet aujourd'hui qui est clivant dans
les états membres de l'union européenne
c'est bien celui ci donc tout le monde
avance avec des pincettes sur ce sujet
sur ce sujet migratoires j'ajoute que
l'europe centrale et orientale pour des
régions qui élit nation histoire ne veut
pas de migrants non européens voilà on
l'a vu lors de la crise de 2015 on
rappelait la déclaration de bratislava
des quatre pays du pacte de visegrad ça
reste très largement aujourd'hui vrai et
donc il avait refusé le principe d'une
solidarité qui
était président de la commission à
l'époque avait conçu un système de
répartition si vous voulez par par
quotas alors en même temps c'est pas
c'est pas non plus très simple à mettre
en oeuvre parce que les conditions de
vie ne sont pas les mêmes dans les
différents états de l'union européenne
si vous prenez aujourd'hui le salaire
moyen de la pologne il est trois fois
inférieur à celui de l'allemagne donc si
vous êtes un immigrant rationnelle les
migrants qui veulent réussir leur vie
sont sont rationnels mieux vaut aller en
allemagne ou mieux vaut aller aux pays
bas qu'en pologne ou en république
tchèque vous voyez il ya d'autres
phénomènes qui s'ajoute comme par
exemple fait que des communautés soient
déjà constitués et si vous avez une
commune c'est exactement ce qui est en
train de de se passer pour la grande
bretagne avec les afghans par exemple
pourquoi est ce que les afghans veulent
absolument aller en grande bretagne par
tous les moyens au péril de leur vie
c'est parce qu'il ya des communautés
afghane en grande bretagne et que la
langue qu'ils connaissent à peu près
c'est la langue anglaise voilà donc vous
voyez tous ces phénomènes qui sont des
phénomènes très très concret ajoute à la
difficulté c'est pas comme si on avait
une union européenne où les conditions
de vie étaient largement harmonie sais
c'est quoi c'est trop compliqué à mettre
en place l'impact sur les opinions
publiques parce qu'on a bien compris en
fait c'est de la nitroglycérine à manier
auprès des opinions publiques
européennes on nous fait rêver sur un
pack qui soi-disant va résoudre les
problèmes ce qui permet d'éviter de
prendre des décisions maintenant d'abord
il faut préciser qu'il y a eu déjà
d'autres pacte sur la migration mon idée
signée au sein de l'union européenne et
qui n'ont pas été respectées dans le
passé donc à supposer même qu'un pack
soit signé demain matin ce qui ne sera
pas le cas il faudra ensuite qu'ils
soient respectés et puis bien entendu il
ya sept du coup on oublie les problèmes
conjoncturels prends un exemple simple
il y un peu plus d'un mois le 12 octobre
douze pays de l'union européenne ont
écrit à la commission pour l'alerter sur
l'utilisation de larmes des
l'immigration notamment par la
biélorussie le 12 octobre oui parce que
demandant un certain nombre de mesures
très précises aucune réponse de l'union
européenne rien n'a été décidé donc ces
tickets tenu que si je puis dire qu'il
conviendrait de prendre des décisions ou
de de remettre impact impact futur mais
le problème de fond le problème de fond
c'est effectivement il faudrait que
l'union européenne une stratégie
migratoire commune mais peut-elle avoir
une stratégie migratoire commune alors
que son attitude face à la migration et
différencié pour des raisons on dirait
doctrine allié au pays mais aussi pour
des raisons économiques
quelles différences entre l'allemagne
dont la population active diminue et qui
a besoin de main d'oeuvre et qui au fil
des années le medef allemand enfin les
patrons allemands réclament de
l'immigration pour satisfaire les
besoins de postes de travail et la
france au contraire qu'un taux d'emploi
très faible qu'un des taux de chômage de
certains immigrés et qui vont jusqu'à
30% et qui n'a pas besoin en fait
d'immigrés non qualifiés je dirais pour
son développement économique
donc nous sommes dans des situations
très différenciée mathieu juste le ce
pacte migratoires il est difficile à
négocier sur le plan européen il est
difficile à négocier sur le plan
français j'ai compris de la part des
modèles macro qui a beaucoup varié sur
le sujet il était pour accueillir
c'était l'honneur de la france dit-il à
côté d'angela merkel au début de son
quinquennat pour l'accueil des migrants
aujourd'hui on n'est plus du tout sur ce
schéma là on a bien vu ce qui s'est
passé pendant le quinquennat on a eu
quand même eu une politique plutôt fermé
couverte est en plein contexte de la
campagne présidentielle pour le coup
c'est de la nitroglycérine
parce que quoi qu'il fasse il se fera
quand même oui on voit très bien que
cette cette arme de la migration et est
utilisé aussi par l'extérieur donc on
revient à vladimir poutine et au
président biélorusse parce que ça
favorise la montée des mouvements les
plus populistes et de plus nationalistes
dans plusieurs états l'allemagne mise à
part parce que le cas allemand est un
peu particulier parce que en allemagne
il faut dire aussi que les la migration
c'est une migration qui est plutôt de
qualité
avec des deux des gens sont assez fort
mais il suffisait de voir quels sont les
syriens qui sont arrivés en allemagne
c'était des médecins c'était des
ingénieurs 2015 jouer c'était d'émigrés
bat plus plus plus en france le problème
de notre migration c'est que ce sont des
bac + 1 ou moins 4 il ya donc là il ya
des vraies différences et les pays qui
veulent effectivement nous perturber
jouer avec nous et bien joue sur ce
nationalisme forcené qui est en train
d'être dans certains de nos pays et
paralyse presque tétanie snow
gouvernement c'est à dire que le
gouvernement français je peux me tromper
mais par rapport à sa soeur risque de
voir la situation s'enflammer sur cette
question migratoire est bien ne dit rien
ne dit pas grand chose et donc senti
leur à la présidence de l'union
européenne peut-être nous réserve-t-il
des surprises fait c'est très difficile
de prendre des décisions au niveau
européen quand les situations politiques
sont purement émotionnel sur une
question sous les l'europe ça nécessite
une forme de rationalisation or là sur
la question migratoire on ne peut pas en
parler rationnellement c'est dommage
parce qu'on pourrait avoir un discours
rationnel notamment ce que vous avez dit
sur le fait d'attirer par exemple de la
main d'oeuvre qualifiée dans le fond
c'est ce que fait le canada alors
évidemment la population n'est pas la
même et c mais on voit des pays où il ya
besoin de main d'oeuvre qualifiée mais
même en france sur certains emplois
qualifiés on aurait besoin d'étrangers
comme ça ça nécessite d'avoir un débat
calme et rationnelle or ça n'est pas
possible ça n'est pas possible le débat
était utile kalmery
c'était un thème central du débat ait
l'air hier soir sur l'immigration
quelques extraits
extraits du débat et l'air hier soir
on aide les polonais à protéger notre
frontière c'est pas la frontière
polonaise ce sont les frontières de
l'europe et on ne sait pas se chante
aujourd'hui nous devons protéger nos
frontières et c'est l'existence même de
l'europe qui est en jeu moi je suis
convaincu que seule la fermeté sera gage
d'humanité l'europe a le 2 voire de
protéger ses frontières c'est une
instrumentalisation des libérer du
régime dictatorial
de loukachenko d'utiliser des sommes
déjà mais des femmes qui arrivent
d'ailleurs par des avions régulier
venant du proche orient et qu'il essaye
de pousser vers l'union européenne pour
déstabiliser l'union europe il faut être
solidaire des polonais mais je vous dis
tranquillement que les polonais depuis
plusieurs mois disent nous on ne veut
pas que frontex nous on ne veut pas de
schengen donc ils jouent de leur côté et
on voit bien quand on est seul eh bien
ça ne marche pas c'est une question
européenne et je remette la sphère de
schengen sur la table mathieu est ce que
c'était on a eu l'impression qu'ils
étaient presque le thème unique du débat
hier son émigration
mais ça veut dire beaucoup de choses sur
ce qui intéresse l'électorat et l'air
directories c'est le premier
jour lépine puisqu'on était sur la
remise en cause du droit du sol qui
désormais partagée dans la quasi
totalité des candidats à ce qu on vers
une forme de permis à points pour les
immigrés eux c'est eric ciotti alors là
une réduction drastique et on parlait de
l'immigration de travail notamment
qualifié selon xavier bertrand lors la
faute ou faute ou réduire notamment même
les étudiants les étudiants qui font
partie du soft power d'accueillir des
étudiants étrangers qui repartent dans
les pays étrangers après bref c'est vrai
que cc ils sont obsédés par
l'immigration en fait une cour derrière
évidemment eric zemmour et marine le pen
qui ont fait de l'immigration leur
principal sujet vouliez dire un mot sur
la mécanique européenne parce que on a
tendance à dire que la présidence
française et donc du 1er janvier au 30
juin et c'est là que les choses vont
pouvoir se faire la réalité est assez
différente sur ce qui n'a pas été
préparé au 31 décembre 2021 à mon avis
ne sera pas décidé dans le premier
semestre une présidence à se prépare des
mois à l'avancé il faut des mois à
l'avancé des négociations secrètes bien
entendu qui ne sont pas officiels pour
que celui qui va présider puisse arriver
à mettre d'accord à l'avancé les
personnes alors évidemment quand il se
déroule un événement comme la guerre de
géorgie bon d'un seul coup le hasard a
fait que nicolas sarkozy était président
se rend là et que du coup il a essayé de
régler le problème comme il pouvait mais
ce qui n'a pas été préparée ne sera pas
voté mais ne serait plus possible pour
emmanuel mode 31 c'est ce qu'on est à
fait tout à l'heure merci merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je rappelle
le titre de olive christian lequesne la
nes la puissance par l'image les états
et leur diplomatie publique c'est aux
presses de sciences po et gérard
françois dumont géopolitique de l'europe
c'est aux presses universitaires de
france